Okay, so that the market has been in a
pretty hefty downtrend the last few days
selling off. We do have a nice big kind
of V bottom forming here
off of a previous swing. So, definitely
in a spot where I think we could bottom.
I also think
it honestly needs another retest here to
form a kind of a head and shoulders.
So, I'm watching that we're spiking up
this morning into a previous swing here
and also this line here is kind of where
this sell-off started, where the market
kind of accelerated. So, I'm thinking we
could give this back up and then that'll
be okay, the move's over and the bigger
picture trend comes back into play or it
just, you know, has a pullback before it
moves higher. So, I think this is a good
area. Um
but also I'm watching if this is kind of
a swing that it's going into cuz if we
look at a smaller time frame
we are just running into the 15 minutes
after the open reversal timing.
And then we just had this we opened up
and had a huge spike up and this is on
the ES chart on a 1-minute.
And so, I'm looking to see
you know, we have a great
overextension spike. These two candles
are huge.
Uh I want to see this is a nice big
bearish candlestick. I actually want to
see how this if it kind of does this.
So, actually I want to get in on a short
here if it breaks this low.
Um the Nasdaq is pretty much the exact
same. Uh it's come up to kind of a level
here previous that previous swing. Um
and you know, there's a lot of green
here in terms of the fair value gap. So,
I think it could come up here and then
actually if it does get going give this
back up. I don't think I'm going to
catch that whole move, but
we're in a volatile market where the
risk reward has good potential.
Um so, just trying to see how it reacts
this level. If it makes a new high, I'm
just going to, you know, stay on the
sidelines.
Um see what it looks like.
Looks like it has made a new high.
Um and the Nasdaq might have actually
not made a new high. So, that's kind of
interesting. The Nasdaq is
as well if we look at it. Nasdaq might
be a better short because the Nasdaq has
been selling off harder
than the ES.
Um
In terms of the swing, they're actually
about the same in terms of
about to give that back up.
So,
just trying to look at that and see,
okay, in real time which one will I
take? But also, if the ES is making new
all-time highs, or not all-time highs,
but making new swing highs
in this current trend we're in, I don't
want to jump in
um short cuz that could just be pulling
the market up, you know, I want both of
them to look bearish. So, right now
looks like it's still punching, but at
10:00 we have some news, and that's kind
of when the re- you know, reversals can
happen as well.
And then maybe by then we'll get up to
this move.
Um and we could, you know, get a even a
even a if it comes up here
and reverses down here, that's a nice
spot as a target, and then, you know,
maybe it cascades further, and we go to
the market open, and that would be a
great trade.
Nice sell off.
I really don't like taking this into the
news,
but also, I'm just thinking that
this we've we're moving, the
candlesticks are huge. Each I mean, this
candlestick is over five points. So, the
news might not actually cause that much
movement.
And if this comes up to here, sells off,
makes a new low, I think that's a great
signal to go short.
It's pretty nice reversal. We have
>> [sighs]
>> 1 minute on news. That's kind of
scary to just
I don't like just getting in right at
news with idea that it's going to cause
some kind of spike.
It could cause a spike lower.
But it could also cause a spike higher.
I want to see
I think I'm going to I'm going to be
patient. Uh cuz
the I'm feeling a little FOMO right now.
I think for good reason just cuz like I
think this is a good signal, but also
being literally 30 seconds from news
that I know is going to be
pretty big.
Um
is a little scary cuz we've got
prelim
this news right here
and
if I go to this thing that I have
that basically I have it recorded as
it's going to be
massive movement
and I need to trade essentially after
the spike happens.
So, here it happens.
I'm going to let it spike a little bit,
move around.
I think if it spikes up higher a little
bit, but doesn't break this, I like
that.
Um Nasdaq is breaking lower.
I think I'm going to put in an order
here.
Nasdaq here is looking good. The hope is
that that drags the ES down.
>> Order filled.
I'm in on a short. I'm just going to
target these low like literally the
open.
Ideally.
Scary thing is uh I should maybe be in
the Nasdaq because that's what's pulling
the market down.
And this is acting a little stronger.
You know, part of me thinks, "Oh, it's
just going to
come down here a little bit and then
bounce, but
I mean, big picture, I think this is a
nice spike that could get flushed.
So,
despite my nervousness, my you know,
plan is going to get in is getting in
and
that's important to follow, you know,
even though you're nervous
um
for certain reasons,
you don't want it to let it control your
actions. You want to
I find just taking deep breaths
really helps pushing through that
emotion and just, you know, saying,
"Hey, I'm I'm getting in for these
reasons, you know, it's at this 10:00
timing
where I think there's a reversal.
There's a this is a nice spike higher.
It came up here and really kind of
tested this. We kind of have a head and
shoulders here.
It's at a good level. There's been a a
flush higher here that I think is likely
to give back up.
I'll most likely go break even once for
the ES here. I think it kind of has to
break this area before it starts to
accelerate and give this back up.
You know, there is this previous high
here. That's why this this what this
range is
made from, but I think, you know, in
terms of getting this move back up,
you know, we could get a little bounce
here and then really start to
accelerate, hopefully.
Nasdaq is looking great.
You know what?
It might find some support here, but
hopefully
um you know, sometimes when the Nasdaq
is sending going ahead, it'll just break
this level. So,
just watching to see that play out.
Also, while we wait for this,
NinjaTrader is having a trading
competition again, where you join for
free. It's just demo trading, but
there's real cash prizes. You can check
it out via the link in the description
or this QR code. It's for new or
returning current users. Looks like
we're just kind of in this downtrend
right here.
Um again, just got to be patient with
it. I don't want to move to break even
yet. I think it could have a little bit
of a pullback here and then continue
lower. Just need to
wait it out.
Nasdaq is still
you know, it's got to where it might
find some support. If it does find
support,
but I want to give this room to play cuz
I do think overall
big picture is
good to the low side. But, it does seem
like there is some spike-ability where
this could just rip higher.
So, we'll see if this just knocks me out
here. If it does, so be it.
>> [clears throat]
>> I think it was a great entry, great
trade.
No matter the outcome. Followed my
rules.
Got in despite feeling really nervous
and kind of emotional about it.
And that's, you know, that's the hard
part about trading is sticking to your
strategy
um when your emotions want you to do
something else. So, looks like I'm an
out there. Only like a $900, $800 loss,
so that's
I'm fine with that. That's like a
half-size loss
when I think it was
very close to
doing this.